the doctor said to me Lindsay you're
going to need to watch out for signs of
rabies but you're apparently increased
irritation foaming at the mouth and
extreme anger I was like Doc I'm pretty
sure I've had rabies since I was four
years old
her comedy is described as take no
prisoners it is a lot of fun she will
skewer everyone everything but in a good
way and she is performing at the Wise
Guys Comedy Club next week welcome
Lindsey Glazer back to the show thank
you so much for being here thank you for
having me so excited for you because
you've been doing great you sold out the
last time you're expected to sell out
again and this is not necessarily how
you started as far as a career is
concerned you were an attorney I was
technically I am still an attorney but
it's the same skill it's performance all
jobs are a sales job
you do it well I mentioned that you
skewer everything everybody but you uh
walk that fine line that make comedians
really funny in that it's not over the
top mean spirited
some people would say it's not over the
top mean spirited maybe not for daytime
TV well you are the alpha B yes right we
won't say here but you're the alphabet
so you do have an edge to you and people
should know that going in but much like
Don Rickles was able to skewer people
and let them know at the same time okay
it's still okay you know things are okay
that's right we only roast the ones we
love right right have you have uh gotten
a lot of your comedy from your daughter
who's now nine years old right yes she's
nine years old she's a firecracker as
they would say she got in trouble last
week and I told her I don't like you or
your behavior very much and she yelled
at me it's not my job to make you like
me it's my job to like myself there's
too much wisdom in that that's scary I
was like angry and proud at the same
time well now you seem likable to me we
had a chance to talk ahead of time but
your daughter uh has a friend who thinks
otherwise right she told me after I said
that to her that this is why my
imaginary friend doesn't like you I said
excuse me and she said yeah she thinks
you're too self-absorbed and I said your
imaginary friend that you made up the
excitement self-absorb said vain yes in
vain and possibly bipolar that's
fantastic all right but Kendall I asked
her I said hey out of curiosity what's
your imaginary friend's name she said
Grandma
[Laughter]
you were in the public Spotlight for a
bizarre reason oh that's right yeah
Scottie Pippen went after you he did
Scottie Pippen sued me I lived in this
house my house was ruined in a hurricane
in Florida uh Scottie Pippen sued me
because he thought it was related to
Malcolm Glazer who the former passed
away owner of the Tampa Bay Bucs thought
you had billions of dollars instead of
yeah whatever instead of you know fives
and tens right yeah exactly how did that
end or how did it come to a conclusion
well how it ended was Scottie Pippen
tried to get me to send sign an NDA
saying I want to talk about it so he
could go on TV and talk about the last
dance in his book settling scores if you
come to the show you'll see how he did
it I'll tell you all about it oh my gosh
that's great we do want to tell people
about where the show is and we also want
to tell people that you have a place in
your heart for military and there's a
special deal for them at your show yeah
that's right if you are military and you
can prove it your first drink is on us
the show is actually at Wiseguys Comedy
Club located in the arts district it's
1511 South Main Street you can get your
tickets by going to the website which is
vegas.wiseguys.com all right let's
review that again Lindsay thanks for
joining us she is going to be at
Wiseguys Comedy Club that's the 16th and
17th of this month and you can go to
vegas.wiseguyscomedy.com right that's
right and they do have the special offer
that we talked about uh if you're in the
mail military can prove it you get your
first drink for free Lindsay it's always
fun to have you here thank you so much
thanks so much all right still